(jazzy music)
- [Voiceover] Salt's delicious as heck.
It goes great on fries, chips, soups,
and all kinds of savory items.
But salt on desserts?
You don't think about it.
So why does salt work so, so, so well
sprinkled on top of
chocolate chip cookies?
Seriously, try it.
Well, one reason it works so dang good
is 'cause sugar tasty and salt is tasty.
So you layer one good flavor on another,
and you got a lot of
good business going on.
Duh.
But that's not the whole story.
Salt is special because
it isn't just tasty,
it has taste-enhancing qualities.
What does that mean?
Adults have hundreds of
thousands of taste receptor cells
that live primarily on our tongues.
Though they also live in the intestines.
- [Voiceover] Gross.
- [Voiceover] Some of these receptors
become activated when
we eat something sugary,
but if you add sodium in to the equation,
some of these sweet receptors that don't
normally activate when we
have just sugar, become alert.
- [Voiceover] Oh shit.
- [Voiceover] This intensifies the sugar.
To get this double punch of sweetness,
a pinch of salt is all you need.
So get to pinching, cookie lovers.
(jazzy music)